hey guys this is andrew for 10senses.com
so for those who are watching my videos
for the first time i'm working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and i decided to make some youtube
videos a few
months ago to explain to you how to use
technical analysis to set up your trades
to understand the market price action
development
and to actually make money on the market
so if you want to know about all the
stuff
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to show you what i
see when i apply all these techniques
on the dutch coin let's get into it
[Music]
so i actually did my first video on the
dutch coin last week
or maybe i did one before it would be
interesting to see what i was saying and
i forgot
but i mean what we're having since last
week is
definitely more interesting to analyze
that
what we had before so here i'm gonna
apply idiot wave principle
to this price action development and i'm
gonna try to see if yes or not
the cycle is complete if it's not
complete i'm gonna use fib extensions to
find the price target
so it's something i've done already but
the
situation has changed a bit so i'm gonna
do it again with you guys and see the
alternative scenarios
and try to see where we might be heading
so
when i do it since inception you know
here i have a beautiful
one two three four five this is complete
this is finished
then here we have a correction abc i
don't know why it disappeared
let me add it
okay abc
now we having a one two
i think three four five all right this
is my view
and the five we were saying it's going
to 0.9
you're gonna see that the target has
changed a little bit now but it's still
gonna be bullish
now so let's focus on everything that
actually
happened since the 23rd of february
okay so let's zoom in
okay so my scenario so let me get rid of
that that's why okay so we see the
beginning all right
so my scenario is that here we do the
one then we correct it in an abc that is
kind of a flat correction i just noticed
something i thought this was a zigzag
which would make this a flat but
actually this is a flat
so this is probably going to be a zigzag
that's one of the rules affiliate with
principle
if second wave is a zigzag fourth wave
is a flat and if
second wave is a flat then the fourth
wave is a zigzag and here i'm having a
flat so
the most common situation is for having
a zigzag here
so let me finish discounting this
counting is good guys because it's
fitting well you know that's on the only
thing you can use is your feeling if yes
or not you're counting is correct
and my fingers tell me that it's correct
because here when i break down
this third wave in one two three four
five so the yellow one
one two three four five then
the third wave here is broken in one two
three four five again
respecting all the rules the third wave
is the most impulsive one
and there are always five waves the
third wave is never the shortest
and you know this is fitting well so
this is
my scenario and let me just show you the
alternative scenario because it's
it's always good to keep this in mind
and then i'm gonna come back to this
preferred scenario but first
why don't i do something like this
okay why and then
the move up would be down and would be
we would be correcting
and we would probably go much lower and
certainly not doing new highs sooner so
why this is not good
two reasons okay first reason is that
let's assume we are like this let's do
this kind of reasoning a reverse
absurd reasoning and this is how we call
it in mathematics you suppose something
is true
and you're gonna come to an absurd
conclusion and so that
the only um reason for that to be absurd
is that your initial
assessment was wrong so let's suppose
it's like this and then we're gonna try
to break down
here my third wave in five waves
so then it's one two it cannot be like
this
it must be like this all right three
four and five okay you follow me
i just broke down this third wave from
two to three
in blue into five waves so now the only
way i have to make it is one
two three here for five because this
wave
is taken so now i do it again
with this third wave and then it cannot
be like this
this must be a five and you see
we're having something absurd
where is the third wave there is no more
oh here okay all right
is it respecting illegal wave rules
i'm afraid it's not guys okay
what is the shortest wave between here
so 12 11 so the third wave is shorter
than the first one
and 17. this is absurd guys because the
third wave would be the shortest in this
counting so discounting
is wrong it cannot be true it's not
respecting
the rules of idiot wave principle if you
want to know about all these rules guys
just click on the link in the
description of this video
and you're going to access my member
zone
where i put free trainings about idiot
wave theory
where i explain everything guys it's
very easy to understand
because i read the books many times so
you can see guys that this is not
working okay
i tried i did my best and one more thing
okay if this is true then here
we having a one two three four five all
right so this actually would be possible
one two this could be a one two it can
be one two if this level the
high i have here if it was higher than
the higher had here
this couldn't be a one two so for now it
could be a one two and maybe three four
five that's possible
but the reason this is not good for me
is that
here i couldn't make my breakdown
properly if i assume that
so my only reasonable assumption is to
consider
that we are like this right and now
here this is fitting better i like it
so and i was telling you guys that i was
seeing here a triangle correction but
now that i see that this is a flat
having a zigzag here makes actually
sense
so we're not sure of anything yet but
this looks good
so right now what we guys are looking
for we are looking for
some more strengths in this market so
i'm going to give you a very easy
technique to use
is trend lines once again guys log scale
don't forget
log scale not regular if i'm on the
regular scale
this looks like this you know how can
you do technical analysis on something
like this you cannot all right
so you use log scale which makes the
price action development
in percentage and not in absolute value
and which is
more easy to read and which makes more
sense actually
and so here what you guys want to see
what you're looking for
is the breakout of this level all right
so when we
break out here it's the right time to
buy okay
i like to buy when the price is going
higher when i have the bullish momentum
with me i don't like to buy when it's
bearish so of course if you guys managed
to buy here all right congrats at the
top of the third wave
and this is actually the bottom of the
sea wave it was missing only a few
cents i mean tens of cents whatever
so if you guys manage to do it well done
i'm not training like this i like to buy
when i have the bullish momentum with me
and here i would have the bullish
momentum with me once
we break this trend line that's
connecting this high this high
and this high so it can happen anytime
it can be at 25 and once again you don't
buy the breakout you can buy the
breakout but i don't do it
you wait for the test and you buy this
if you have a breakout here
you then buy this level which is usually
lower and you can find some support area
in this
here and so it would be around 22 cents
if we break out on monday and so the new
target i use the same technique
but just my low is lower
and i use fib extension i measure the
third wave bam
bam i applied to the bottom of my false
wave and the 1.618 is the
most common number the most common ratio
we're going to reach
so it's 0.79 so it decreased a bit guys
it was 0.9 but
we bottomed here lower so it's lower as
well
so let's call it 0.8 so i think we're
gonna
go to 0.8 before correcting deeper now
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys